play everybody Bob it's not like five in
a row now hello hello everybody welcome
to Dutch boy stur with me
it's yeah in my scrim that's cuz his
last name is my scrim whoa hey cause
we're gonna find me yeah totally man
I'm Olli so far I'm only friends with
one person who's the fan of this huh and
I'm not saying who it is
we're still recording for the last bit
so I got to finish off my wine here I
thought yours last day was like Vic's
cruise skirt oh yeah well it if we're
talking illegally he goes he goes by my
skirt go bye-bye okay anyway so yeah
like like how you go by Wade yeah
exactly
good and so listen wait a minute don't
tell people that
wait no yeah I know I'm sorry for your
knee gob we got to get going cuz we got
to do stuff cuz so important that we do
stuff not really cause no one would do
it the last leg eat cheated on dice no
okay what I've enjoyed that one where I
built this house and you [ __ ] didn't
do [ __ ] we were down in the mines
slaving our hands to the bone about
getting coal well I'm currently filling
up a giant chest with mushroom stew so
we don't die of hunger you have so many
mushrooms news is I made a hundred
twenty bowls when it happens to all of
Mara dick so many slime balls God last
episode was this unbelievable shrimp
must pick up all your crap hey hey yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
another that I am going to farm you guys
do over the hell you wanted I'm farming
mushrooms
I want to trap the mushrooms I just want
to point out a trap like two of them you
know then I guess where the [ __ ] did you
get diamond I had diamond zombie didn't
take it away from me when we started I
have it yeah you can have a diamond
whatever I don't give a [ __ ] won't make
I have three diamonds that's really the
crucial number why all you need is a
home I want a pick I want
hey yo ho I'm gonna trample all your
[ __ ] until you give me diamonds
I'm Jesus I have three here take them ah
yes oh wait water huh what are you doing
wait what my way why are you doing I
don't think wave yes the idea my view
are right this way you want the water
no before wait water can only go like
three blocks away water only hydrates
farm three blocks away don't you know
that I might be wrong in that but I'm
still calling you an idiot I'm pretty
sure you're right mark because yeah I
know no reason to look dull shot don't
bring that back way
Julie Matthews um wait yeah we don't
know what an ocean we don't know if the
viewers enjoyed that Rick Matthews but
bath do it every single Mac you're gonna
we're adorable don't don't let him ask
you something
Wow mom you coming mother sorry girl
okay this land is trampled such a shitty
wicked shut up I'm trying I don't have
the water
uh water we're gonna shovel your dick
here I'm gonna iron house hop that was
iron get that iron get the iron get the
hard come on
okay hahaha why didn't you throw 32 iron
it oh you're complaining no why did you
do it Vic ah Oh nine times out of ten
I'm already dead by this point in
episode yeah so cherish it wait
appreciate this appreciate it
eat it I'm gonna kill you don't know
everything but is wrong you're
everything that is wrong with drunk
minecraft you're everything that is
wrong with America there's a my really
everything that's wrong with Joe
everything yeah this would be a
chromatic series we have so many more
viewers if you what you didn't do your
thing
what yeah you heard me what words did
you just say you learn things all the
fangirls to the yeah right you're uh I
went there he like Molly I could teach
away you Molly but I'd have to angry
we're at a point where we don't know
what happened with that Holly we don't
know what happened with that I know
you're watching I know you're gonna
watch this again just to see that way
watches the age I will personally like I
am violating minecraft laws written wait
she could have shot you down like
hardcore but he does it what's you have
10,000 subscribers what small am I
talking to you know where's Molly your
diary about does she know which Molly
I'm talking about I know which Molly
you're talking about you think you know
shut up stop that dog you think you had
a date with Molly we know you didn't
there we go
now Bob did on it way to go how do you
know what I'm referencing I just was
copy oh yeah wait Bob doesn't want to I
could not even tell you what that is
that I just did Oh something about
zombies or so we can't go into too many
spoilers in case people are watching and
they don't know spoilers about what
Walking Dead oh it's a show about
zombies then see you at the very end
something exciting happens yeah yeah
wait such a piece of [ __ ] you are I know
well wait that we've always known that
there's some kind of thing that happens
at the end of season two that makes you
want to see season three zombies are
dead in it some zombies learn how to
love you you're free to stay me in the
code did you know that there's a zombie
movie coming out about a zombie that
eats some girls boyfriends brain and
falls in love with this girl because of
that yeah that's the kind of zombie
movie I want to see like so I don't even
remember what that's like so whatever
yeah it's like so whatever exactly is
that what else doing you would have to
be like so whatever look I don't like
this from some stupid-ass book about a
stupid-ass plot about a zombie who
learns to
love which is just a stupid-ass idea
anyway
does he sparkle in the sunlight anyway
yeah hate is so much I hate everything
about it so much it makes me angry every
time I think about it gosh oh go bad
hey Mark how do I join a job job slash
job space blah blah blah whatever you
want to join type slash job space list
to find out what do you want to do
alrighty I'm a miner yeah I'm gonna go
mine going not be allowed to drink or
vote
that's so funny it's original joke yeah
ow you think you're funny boots you mom
I got away I'm gonna punch you in your
goddamn face filiz face hole face hole
that's kind of personal
yeah your face hole uh-huh stay away
from my face holes oh and before anyone
says we know that you don't need water
to grow it just makes it more convenient
also it gives them something to do cuz
really stupid guys yeah totally Wade's
really stupid guys Oh groan hey I found
the base of the penis it's birthday it
seemed like a cavern underground what do
you do well I found I found the base of
the penis are you okay I say oh how did
you get in there you were just digging
holes weren't you or was that wade
that's me oh those Wade oh well I
thought you were useful well you were
being useful so I thought you were Bob
for a second there ah ah ah it's just a
way oh you're a dick basically how did
you get down there hold it you ready oh
I didn't shut up Wade who me yeah
where'd you go he disappeared I'm go
around to the right of the penis I know
I see okay your name is there I see you
know I feel like disappeared for a
second han wait pan Hey look iron
oh no that Hey oh no that's a glitch
where would you go there
right down here with my hi hi hi oh I
see what you mean this must be the
epididymis of the shaft of the
epididymis yeah totally it's that ass
different um the what I forget the size
James oh never mind
penis bits where Sumida ball are the
important part - wait you're boring
you're boring boring your piece [ __ ]
ha ha next one something I was [ __ ]
it over - ha ha ha ha ha oh you just
poor I was underground I was underground
uneasy okay good ah man I don't have any
iron keep digging you douche can can I
get a wooden bowl love of love oh well
sure try if you can I'd be amazed up
nope I gave up I'm still farming cuz I'm
a farmer oh this cow looks angry I'm
vamoose cow look Julia give me your milk
thank you I'm just gonna kill the [ __ ]
out of these cows did you know that it
cows aren't milked regularly they are in
great pain because their cow boobs get
really big yes their cow boobs get
tremendously big is that a fair
assessment you know you're right when
you're right you're right so what are
you killing the cows cuz [ __ ] cows cows
just gave me milk and [ __ ] pigs - okay
Pig - actually I'm gonna use all the
leather I just got to make a saddle and
you're gonna ride a pig you're gonna
ride a pig if good you know what I wish
you could do I wish you could ride a pig
man that would be awesome
I'll be a thing boy a mod I would go
through a lot of effort to do that like
I would do some really weird and
excessive things just to get whatever
weird excessive the things I I don't
know what concerns you about that but
you know like be misconstrued as dream
get a lot of blocks or or you know
strange sex stuff yeah yeah
yeah that makes sense oh whatever
whatever it takes by the way I'm still
taking open applications for girlfriend
positions did you get any we don't know
it that episodes not even I know bad
core should still take am I supposed to
know that it's all like I subscribe to
your Shh ha ha ha ha ha wait ha ha ha oh
yeah you left but you're Sam's dad now
oh it's you sad because it's true my
channel is deception
oh man I all the favor that I had for
myself well if it built up all of the
built-up fans that I had slowly emulated
all gone yeah no one likes me anymore no
some of them probably agree with you
like I could no I could try have you
seen the comments on your videos huh
there's only one guy who ever dislikes
any of her videos and everyone thinks
he's a dick have probably that yeah no
you're right is that you
no I can't I don't actually I do like
some of your videos but I feel compelled
not to sway anything since I'm
technically part of it oh yeah I guess
so I comment but I usually don't like
kissing uh it's it's you know no one
cares what I think and so that's not
like people could see who likes and who
doesn't but it done oh really own people
can't seem big or what's the point it's
just I like something I like it because
I want people to know that I like it's
Facebook you're thinking about not like
that likes aren't like that way or Bob
Iowa yeah well like hates you and your
internet girlfriend who probably shot
you down before this recording you and
your internet supermodel pornstar girl
yeah probably not even real how many get
back to the good old days dicks or why
it doesn't say anything true not Molly
now I'm not talking about Molly I'm
talking about his pornstar girlfriend
yeah little girlfriend Chester that
Molly as you're watching that's to see
her name's chastity best porn star name
ever ha ha like I like a lot of irony in
life horns are they sadness and irony so
that's a good that's a good porn star
name 2x
at this an artisan irony get it oh
that's so horrible daddy issues
so dad yeah well if there was a male
porn star whose name was daddy issues ha
ha ha ha ha that o is like tattooed on
his dick just - yes hey are we horrible
people or what yeah no we've already
stabbed
I'm out here digging this flippin farm
this is where wade Lifan flippin hey we
gotta keep a member of flight of the
conchords something ought to keep it PG
guys I'm finna spread purity B's gosh
darn ya there monkey flippin keep going
tool box oh that's a little offensive
sorry I wrote it
I'll Charlie come up this on the for
douchebag what wait whoa
boys go Don we're getting poured it all
over the place uh-oh what's going on
where am I Oh God please Marcus you
really nazi zombie mark no I do not what
happened I don't know what happened to
me oh whoa whoa just going on the ground
I've cleverly hiding from them up in a
tree my hand is often my mouse yeah what
is going on and fear whoa hello
you okay Wade I'm good I look so good
you cannot go for your beers all you
said I did ha ha ha crap the iphone's
covered in beer now it's gonna smell
that's good for it well you just get an
iphone5 then that's yeah cuz it looks so
freakin amazing it looks brand its
groundbreaking mark remember what about
it it's a half-inch taller it's got its
got some brushed aluminum on the back so
it's kind of like a MacBook Pro and well
that's what they like that's what people
who buy iPhones go is it fast later
actually it is faster to be fair does it
have these battery life purportedly the
a6 is much better oh that's good for the
end yeah it's supposed to have battery
battery life but well that's good
because some of the apps on the iPhone
4s were running kind of slow well do you
ever really weird away if
ragging on technology I know I just I
can't tell if you'd like it I don't like
me or like don't like it is sweet not
growing it anyway that we're talking
about it I don't know it's I was
disappointed because I would I would
have expected some you know for it to be
because the four nothing unique about it
I mean and if it was like the four SS
but given that it's the iPhone the 4s to
give us stealing some Samsung giving it
as a for s5 you would have expected
something like revolutionary beside new
software but what is it mark the forest
the iPhone five fish the 4s 5 4s did I
say that yes haha you see it like what
shut up way no I donated about that
that's over hexer Noah's saying that's
not mine we're not trying to copy you're
copying on YouTube
no one does derivative stuff on YouTube
oh no way no no if there's anything I
know about YouTube it's that 97% of the
content is completely original yeah yeah
totes mcgoats totes my notes
don't you knows oh I don't that didn't
83 no we did would give me would I have
so much where you are give me so much
wood I'm ready do you want something I
do where where you are put it in my hand
here why am i digging in the meadow
Chuck testicle why aren't you what we're
doing thank you
has had enough it's too much it's too
much I can't handle it I know we've been
doing this too long whatever I can say
why am i digging in a giant testicle and
not even think twice about it oh god I
need honestly who hasn't been there
we're gonna make some globe yeah sure no
no no no I agree with them that that's
right mark knows what I'm saying
mo knows what I'm talking about I don't
know it's what I'm talking about no one
gets for you MO and gets that reference
mo might get it he subscribes she did
he's a subscriber ship in the middle of
the air what a watch what the giant [ __ ]
were know oh look what the hell I know
is that it's bad news whatever
it's probably good right no yeah
something what something like that
appears it's probably a good thing only
tokes oh I'm gonna go say hello
totes mix gross this sounds like this
looks like it it's drop your it's a frog
bog I know it's like a weird like that
guy in the lightning Percy Jackson and
the lightning thief I think this is
Percy Jackson right what oh I'm who the
hell is Percy Jackson ah some douchebag
who makes movies about lightning what
don't make holes in it you douche who's
doing what I'm building I'm building up
an empire and you guys are just [ __ ]
around we're exploring the alien Odyssey
the ship I saw the ship I wasn't that
interested in this ship holy crap whoa
what what is this what what what's on us
go how did you get up there
oh no I put the suck of dry see how did
you get up there I put the I put the
fire out is that bad fuel 85 what can
you actually fly that thing oh my god
mark I've asked that question already
well I'm the only put the fires out
though so I I it doesn't seem like a
good thing I'm here now mark you're so
behind the times
Hey look at this oh man I made so many
mushroom stews shouldn't that I put it
wrong hey on I got I got floor plug to
the top and take a look at our penis
okay we'll do that sounds good I like
that idea
looks good oh do what the hell I always
like taking a look at what I got you
know wha hmm there's one piece of glass
and there's a hole in the penis and
there's vines curling up the side are
those pubes oh I don't know
Steve kind of flat on the top that's
gonna weird
that old judge did oh god okay now
that's our penis that's our brain is
yeah okay Oh son of a
you finally phone nothing yeah keep your
PG keep it PG
yeah see that's why I was angry
why did you boohoo friggin put out the
fire who dug a hole in the bottom hey
there's a portal here make this hive of
darlin
Thomas a portal to nowhere yeah it's a
portal no it's not even lit I want to
marry there go out why is there hole in
the roof Bob Bob didn't steal another
one oh that was really funny I'm glad I
got out of there when I did why just
team PD ha ha ha ha ha beer oh yeah that
Ybor wide I swear wha mark oh hi oh hi
Bob
hey ladders are you speaking of Dexter
Dexter Morgan Dexter is starting up soon
real soon
that's what that's why I'm Dexter it's
what inspired this skin really is that
what is it did you do that yeah
why did you stutter did I stutter it
sounded like you were mocking me but you
bought something that I didn't do no I I
just I stuttered there hey people are
fans of mine where's this new she oh
there it is it's up don't screw it up
this time
whoa Wow I got ported up all right I'm
up here I'm gonna go here we go what
Nick Nick stop all these
that's how do we get it to go how do we
get it to go
I'm gonna go up to the maneuvering
engine or whatever the new really what
how do I get a sheep's we all see the
times where we miss all being able to
tell us what to do
who put this wood air I'm not put
anything anywhere wait what places sign
ships airship markiplier what Logan Ruth
oh I get it
I have a sign what I'm gonna win what
what thing about we're racing I don't
know what where did that pit of lava
come from I'm so continued right now oh
this is so weird that's the lava I died
in that one time dying it again because
I hate you oh no what are you gonna do
why are you gonna do we gonna do uh it
Revathy Oh what are you gonna do Rick
you ain't got the guts to carry through
whatever you think you're doing Rick
you're the one bringing up the voice now
Shane I'm the only one who can lead this
group Rick that's what you think but
it's not true at not how the quote goes
Rick I need some sheep that's also not
how the quote goes Rick need to make a
bed on here and ask you Sean may the
love that we share
Matthew Xiang I'm willing to put this
behind us if you're willing to put this
in this I'm sorry look I'm sorry but
this is hahaha okay said oh shut up John
Wayne again shut up Bob
shut up pilgrim you think I can't quote
Rick butch you're wrong apparently
you're wrong cause you can't apparently
I am ask you some who do you think
you're doing an impression of now me ask
me something I saw what this job it when
you're embarrassing yourself that's what
I do I'm the only one who can embarrass
myself and keep going
have the balls for that you you're the
worst my truck my craft episodes ever
it's just so bad if this is one of your
favorite episodes to drop minecraft
please say so in the comments really
below sound all official now it's the
best I could do
I can't make it work zombies trying to
make it work is not what we're I don't
see zombie he's dead right I do not see
zombie you're going ray nope knows I see
the Sun family appearing nope he just
actually did just vanished fuel it's got
no fuel we gotta put fuel in it if you
give me fire give me that which others
are putting fuel in it guys sing
Metallica is that copyright infringement
Eliquis I'm getting sued they don't like
it gotta be careful about that looks uh
sounds so much like yeah Bobby we got we
got it's like the blood sugar the blah
blah la estoy jugando hoon is estoy
wound estoy haha you're so bad huh no
I'm so good who thinks I'm good at there
who thinks I'm good at Spanish no one
thinks you're good your honor
Oh live died I died oh [ __ ] I jumped
after you why why you said you live God
you guys are stupid I thought I lived it
didn't work out oh good okay alright so
back to brass tacks um airship is now
abandoned cos zombie can't get you to
work I'm on it you're not on it it's
mine I called it fine you be a dick it's
my airship and no one can come on wait
why did you have to get all your [ __ ] in
the middle of my [ __ ] we can't even do
anything I think that much I want to
punch you hi everyone just so everyone's
clear I'm punching wait not disturb
what's clear I wanted to play where oh
hang on
TP oh that's right my my yeah I don't
even have to put in the full name I'm so
badass
let me make it work Bobby you think he's
here but he isn't your lord is that his
hair mask you Shum you're the one who
said he is here Rick I saw him before
but I don't see him now Shan mask you
showed up just Matthews younger hold on
if I have a knot with Lori if you give
me $10 we can arrange that I mean they
she's mom was saying things in that tone
of voice it not working is not how good
your honor mom missed Geronimo ha ha ha
pop I am stuck that's the idea waves you
know that's the idea waited sure is
now you're just sick well maybe we
should get started saying things now
that's John Wayne that's young like that
gently yes we should pilgrim John Wayne
quota I apparently know that's the only
thing he ever said in all of his movies
he'll groom maybe we say pilgrim pilgrim
Oh God
whose line is anyway Ryan Stiles I loved
his John Wayne impression everything you
did about John Wiggles is just my
favorite ever like honest to god wait
you saw oh no Bob wait why Bobby why I
waited but what's going on up there why
wait why haven't busted that out in a
long time oh oh
abandon ship holy how do you mark ha ha
ha hi no that's all I sell my you guys
are more I stuff is gonna be mixed in
with your stuff oh oh oh oh god this is
fun
ridiculous what every Tommy says it's
working it's working
wait some poor poor me what is sexless
bad oh there's so much crap right here
god damn it wait I swear I hate you so
much raise your hand if you hate wait
guys just ruins everything he touches
just everything he ruins it okay I
raised my bar guy just typed in /tpaot
markiplier DeBell ah oh no Bob you're
not it okay there we go oh are you up
there up here hey I gotta get this going
here yes all right all right how do we
do it up no that's not right hang on I
got it wait something about oh man who
broke this ship whoa god damn it I turn
the ship boy it oh wow what oh that's on
ahead are we moving to you are you
selling us my turn yeah we're moving
we're moving we're moving I think I
don't know I'm stuck now why is going on
I'm making us go up up turning the ship
as much as this is the best ship ever oh
[ __ ] no no no oh my god why we're
actually we're out
Hey all right I'm the only one ship now
sure sure okay we're actually out of
time
oh I can do that two hands yeah no wait
maybe that did not know no was gonna do
this do down my voice okay all right
that's enough we got it
we got out of here all right so thank
you everybody so much for watching hope
you enjoyed it write in the comments if
you still like the 30 minutes if you
think we're idiots if you think Wade is
a douche whatever just read they got
this
so after Shui Acastus Astor's yeah
that's correct
Thank You butters all right thank you
all so much watching and we're as always
we'll see you in the next